hello everyone welcome to a video on
code tech tutorials doing a video on a
different computer this time
here is Linux it's a Debian distribution
and we're gonna talk about Vulcan I just
went through getting Vulcan set up and
ready for development on this little
laptop and it's running an Intel 620
video card so it's not AMD or Nvidia so
I had to go through a few I wouldn't say
special well maybe special things I
basically just want to walk you through
what I had to do to get it running and
it wasn't actually all that much a few
basic Google searches got me started
pretty good but I did have a few very
specific commands that I had to type in
to get the right video drivers so the
Nvidia are the just a video driver in
general for me it's Intel
well let me just find that command here
been a while back let's see here
it was sudo apt-get install mesa balkan
drivers this was the big thing that I
was missing none of the tutorials or
anything really had this particular
apt-get install but the Mesa Vulcan
drivers are required for Intel but in
general and by the tutorials I really do
just mean the tutorials like if you
search for a Vulcan tutorial you get
some you know observe read a little
you'll find the basic getting started
guide and basically what you end up
doing is downloading it a SDK so Vulcan
SDK and you can find that at lunar Chi
so lunar Jie created this basically it's
like mostly validation layer and some
helpful stuff to help wrap Volken and
make sure the end user doesn't mess
things up too bad so it's the sdk and
it's made by another company so when you
go to download it you pick whatever you
want I pick Linux so that's what I'm
walking through here it's how to do it
on Linux and you get a tar you gotta
untie it I already did that you're
getting stuck on how to on tar things
that's uh well the commands are there
and that in the readme somewhere or in
one of the tutorials so I kind of want
to skip past all that stuff because you
can read about it and do it if you want
let me know if you would like a
walkthrough on something like that it's
just a little more tea is to record
rather than just pop it on at the end
when everything's done okay so let's
move on a little bit so I got the Vulcan
SDK you can see it here
and what you have to do let me just go
to that directory
ya see 1.2 okay so this is where
unzipped it unzipped it to this Vulcan
SDK location I untied it to there so now
I'm in that folder let's see what we got
here there's this Vulcan SDK executable
so you can run that and it sets
everything up for you it does give you
some usage information you can just do
all if you want everything just want the
samples you can do samples I first did
all and it took forever so your
experience may vary but if you just
build the samples
I'll show you where it puts those and
how to run all the samples that's
actually what I have open right here in
the background with Visual Studio code
is the samples so here's the draw cube
and there's also the ones I was most
interested immediately it was like how
do you draw stuff basically right but as
you can see there's a lot of stuff here
and one of these is draw texture cube
there it is so they've got all that
ready to go for you now there's a really
cool thing I want to talk about in here
about how they set it up and initialize
it and it's kind of it's sort of
revolutionary because if everyone just
did this it would be way easier for
development in general cross-platform
development especially okay so close
this close this go back to my terminal
this or the interesting stuff is
happening so okay so we build it this
has built pipeline cache now if I just
look at the directory again I can see
I guess samples is where we go
you know let's change directory into
samples
and we see a build folder here so this
is where all the runnable czars in this
build but if you want to look at the
source it's in this sample program here
so I actually have open with Visual
Studio code and I'll just show you that
folder and that way you can kind of view
them all and view all the code oh this
is hologram this is the wrong folder
it's the yeah let's just back up here
this is actually an API samples I'm
going back to gar okay samples and then
API samples so the other samples one is
just hologram which is actually pretty
cool too
I'll show you that real quick just for
full whatever full something alright so
here we are
there's hologram Oh fits within a folder
again hologram there it is
all the build stuff so we can run it and
here's that hologram program doing with
this this with OpenGL pretty cool right
all right so let's go back to the API
sample C API samples is where all the
code is so you can open that this whole
thing with the original studio code and
see all the different projects here and
see how they link stuff and the really
cool thing that I want to talk about is
just how they do the windowing I've been
messing around with like OpenGL and
going back and forth between the windows
1 and OpenGL and looking at how to do it
on Mac and Linux in you know GL FW it
kind of solves the cross-platform
problem then you have another dependency
in your program well you can use all
just the native windowing and they show
you our valve and lunar G have a sample
file that has it all right here so this
is super awesome bit of code it's right
here and this process command line art I
go to definition they have a utility VP
and it processes to him hold on actually
that's not what I wanted I'll show you
it's this innate global layer properties
one of these here let's look at this
struct sample info yeah okay the sample
info struct that they pass in and
initialize with it has all the window
info so first it looks is is it windows
so create a windows window handle just
the native one from from windows why not
just use that if you're on Windows and
if you're using metal which is a Mac you
get that you're on Android you get that
one and if you're on Whalen you get that
display and if you're on something else
it's an x cb connection you're on linux
which is what i'm on you get the links
one so just right here there's all the
different windows for all the main oh s
is and you don't need to use jill @w you
just need preprocessor stuff so I
thought that was really cool and I'm
probably gonna try to work with that in
the future I think it just makes sense
Volken seems like it's the way to go
because everything supports that it runs
on everything OpenGL is being
depreciated no real need to dive more
into that although I kind of would like
to learn more I think I'm just going to
move on in the rendering studies because
I want something that's basically easy
and doesn't bring me too much worry and
I think Vulcan once setup properly would
be that especially with just the
cross-platform ability you know you can
just code your game once and keep using
the same rendering stuff or you know all
your stuff and if Vulcan updates you
just update it along with it no big deal
but at least you don't have to worry
about it becoming depreciated and
stopping working on some certain system
so there you go hope you guys are able
to get this running I know I didn't go
over a whole lot of that but I don't
know it's pretty cool to play around
with it let's just run some of this I
guess I'm gonna run this drawing
cube let's see here oh wait we gotta go
back we gotta go to the build directory
that's where that script builds it then
go into okay and then it's texture draw
extra cube i'm just i just opened the
window and i think my face is in front
of it on this OBS thing so i'll go i'll
go down here don't mind me yeah that's
literally it all does so all these have
been built you can run any of them
there's another one that's just cube
it's like they just have it closed right
away i don't know if these others are
like something that actually does
something on the screen there we go yeah
that does something copy clip image draw
sub passes so you can run all these and
look at all the code to all of them and
i think this is like that mean this is
as good of an introduction as it gets
for diving right into balkan really is
just getting an sdk diving into the
sample code and starting to use it
so anyways hope you enjoy this stuff
happy everything hope you guys are doing
well take care of yourselves out there
and i'll see you in the next episode
here on code tech news toriel's peace
out